tanto podría impactar este plan como su
nombre lo indica en la reducción de la
inflación
pues a ver yo creo que hay un componente
que puede ayudar que es la expectativa
que bajen los precios de la insulina por
ejemplo por la capacidad que va a tener
el gobierno federal de negociar con las
compañías con los hospitales con las
compañías de seguros con las
farmacéuticas etcétera para poder
disminuir los precios de la medicina yo
creo que ese es el factor principal la
verdad que esto no hace mucho desde el
punto de vista de disminuir el costo de
la gasolina disminuir el costo de los
alimentos es lo que más está afectando a
los ciudadanos de eeuu en este momento
enfoques como el cambio climático y la
salud de los estadounidenses encabezan
este plan deben ser estas las
prioridades del gobierno
pues a ver yo creo que a mí me gusta
muchísimo todos los planes que hay de
estímulo para para ayudar a que crezca
más las para que crezcan más las
energías alternativas creo que eso es
una buena noticia nuestros subsidios
adicionales para mejorar te de la
electrificación o sea perdón de volver
más eficiente el sistema eléctrico de
eeuu etcétera la hay unas estimaciones
que con esta con la ayuda de este plan
eeuu podría disminuir hasta en 50 por
ciento sus emisiones de aquí hasta 2030
comparado con el 2005 y eso es una buena
noticia entonces hay que ponderar eso
porque va por el camino adecuado desde
el punto de vista del futuro del clima
en el planeta ahora cómo afectará esta
medida a las grandes empresas por
ejemplo a la industria automotriz
pues a ver esto digamos está esta
legislación tiene además o incluye un
impuesto mínimo corporativo a nivel club
después digamos a nivel global que
disminuye la capacidad que tienen
algunas corporaciones digamos de
incorporarse en otros países pagaron los
impuestos menores entonces algo de
incremento se va a ver también por este
lado y creo que también hay una cosa
importante que es en mejorar digamos la
capacidad de gestión de la oficina de
impuestos de eeuu teniendo más gente y
me parece completamente lógico que se
busque pues en las personas que no están
pagando los impuestos que deberían pagar
entonces creo que esto esto podría
ayudar en una forma importante y desde
el punto de vista de las automotrices
pues digamos en los mayores estímulos
que van a ver para para la compra de
carros eléctricos pues deberían ayudar
también a que las compañías que tienen
la vanguardia en términos de la
producción de vehículos eléctricos con
cero emisiones pues les va a ir bastante
bien bajo esta
este plano entonces creo que son cosas
ponderables a mí me gustó me gustó mucho
esta legislación comparado con la
legislación inicial que quería probar el
presidente baile